bien chers amis dans ce paysage
politique si liquide
devant ce pouvoir qui godille nous ne
sommes pas le parti d en même temps nous
sommes les républicains des femmes et
des hommes aux cuivres solide aux
valeurs bien trempé libre aux âmes
faibles et opportuniste de zigzaguer
nous nous marchons droit vers notre
mission s'opposer à tout ce qui
affaiblit la france et reconstruire tout
ce qui fait la grandeur de la france
certains rêvaient de diviser notre
famille politique mais nous faisons
encore bloc
ce matin nous avons élu à la tête du
conseil national jean leonetti c'est un
homme dont les qualités morales et la
sage pondération démontre s'il en était
besoin que la sensibilité centriste
qu'il incarne et bien à l'intérieur de
notre famille c'est le premier conseil
national où j'ai l'honneur de m'adresser
à vous dans mon nouveau rôle de
secrétaire général je dis à laurent
wauquiez cher laurent toute ma gratitude
pour la confiance dont ils m'honore je
suis fier de succéder à bernard accoyer
qui a su tenir le gouvernail dans les
tempêtes que nous avons affrontée
je mesure l'ampleur de ma tâche je me
consacrerai à fond ma devise est simple
travailler pour tous agir et reconquérir
quant à ma feuille de route auprès de
laurent wauquiez
elle est de ressouder nos liens de
respecter chaque militant de ranimer la
flamme de notre mouvement dans nos
fédérations de faire de notre siège
national la maison de tous la droite
on pensait l'avoir définitivement
assommé et tout fait eh bien elle est de
retour
j'en veux pour preuve mes chers amis les
adhésions ont doublé depuis l'élection
de notre président
elle a un chef un chef dont la voix
porte euros vous avez pu vous en rendre
compte
encore jeudi soir sur france 2 certes
certes laurent est très attaquée mais
c'est le privilège des hommes de
caractère les insipides eux ne fâche
personne dans un instant sont
renouvelées avant l'été les membres de
l'équipe dirigeante et moi auront visité
toutes les fédérations de france
notre but est d'écouter remobiliser
détecter les talents ouvrir nos portes à
la société civile moderniser nos
pratiques partisanes
telles sont les perspectives que j'ai
confiée à la tulle talentueuse équipe
qui entoure le rang ils sont jeunes ils
sont expérimentés
ce sont pour beaucoup de nouveaux
visages mais ils savent aussi qu'ils
s'inscrivent dans une histoire qui n'est
pas né avec eux notre mouvement vient de
loin ils portent des valeurs françaises
il a sa fierté il à son honneur il a
connu des victoires il a traversé de
cruelle épreuve mais il est toujours là
toujours vivant fort de ses militants
fort de ses parlementaires et de ses
milliers d'élus locaux qui sont notre
république
nous ne sommes pas les enfants gâtés de
la politique
nous sommes des combattants et des
convaincus nous avons un devoir celui de
faire vivre un débat démocratique qui
soit utile à la france un débat à la
hauteur des enjeux et des défis de notre
temps
nous sommes pour la réussite nationale
pas pour le consensus où on peut tout à
la fois souhaiter le succès de la france
sans mettre un genou à terre devant un
président de la république qui aime si
peu la critique mais dont la politique
n'est pas irréprochable
nous devons débusquer la vérité derrière
les 10
chômage à son pic hausse des impôts
dette abyssale
le bilan de l'année de macron est loin
d'être resplendissant et puis et puis
chers amis il ya les finances les angles
morts ce dont on ne parle pas et qui est
pourtant essentielle quelle est la
réponse du gouvernement au
communautarisme qui grognent gangrène la
nation quelle est la réponse du
gouvernement aux territoires perdus pour
la liberté des femmes
sheikh valérie quelle est la réponse du
gouvernement face aux attaques de plus
en plus nombreuse contrôleur l'autorité
de l'état
cher eric quelle est la réponse du
gouvernement face à l'injustice
territoriale chaire damien sur
l'identité française sur la culture sur
l'écologie sur la famille sur l'europe
nous allons faire entendre la voix
singulière de la droite une droite qui
ne marche pas à l'ombre une droite fier
et moderne une droite populaire et non
populiste une droite unie et diverses
qui a des racines pour ne pas trembler
et des ailes pour voler vers l'avenir
voilà mes amis notre mission et notre
ambition
[Applaudissements]